IN PART TO FUND EFFORTS THAT
WOULD UNDERMINE AMERICAN
ELECTIONS.
>> THIS IRS DOCUMENT OBTAINED BY
CNN IS EVIDENCE OF THE LARGEST
ANONYMOUS DARK MONEY POLITICAL
DONATION EVER REPORTED.
$1.6 BILLION.
IT IS, ACCORDING TO EXPERTS, A
STAGGERING AMOUNT.
>> I'M JUST STUNNED.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT INCOME THAT
IS MANY MULTIPLES LARGER THAN
THE LARGEST DARK MONEY GROUPS
EVER FOUND.
>> IT'S GOING TO A NEW
ORGANIZATION CALLED MARVEL
FREEDOM TRUST.
WHILE YOU HAVE PROBABLY NEVER
HEARD OF IT OR THE MAN IN CHARGE
OF IT, THE WHOLE COUNTRY IS
FAMILIAR WITH HIS WORK.
HIS NAME IS LEONARD LEO, A
DEVOUT CATHOLIC KNOWN AS DONALD
TRUMP'S SUPREME COURT WHISPERER.
>> THERE ARE LOT OF REALLY SMART
PEOPLE WHO CAN SERVE ON THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT.
DOZENS AND DOZENS.
BUT YOU NEED PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COURAGE.
>> LEO HELPED USHER IN THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE SUPREME COURT IN
DECADES.
ALONG WITH HELPING BLOCK MERRICK
GARLAND FROM THE COURT, HE AND
HIS COLLEAGUES AT THE FEDERALIST
SOCIETY ARE GIVEN CREDIT FOR THE
CONFIRMATIONS OF NEIL GORSUCH,
BRETT KAVANAUGH, AND AMY CONEY
BARRETT.
>> IT WAS LEO WHO WAS IN THE
DRIVER'S SEAT OF THOSE
NOMINATIONS.
LEO IS THE PERSON WHO CAN RAISE
THE MONEY AND HAS THE BACKGROUND
TO PUT IN PLACE JUDGES WHO WILL
BUILD A CONSERVATIVE JUDICIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
>> LEONARD LEO NOW HAS AN
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF CASH TO
SPEND ON WHATEVER POLITICAL
PROJECTS HE LIKES.
AND WHILE THE DONATION WAS MEANT
TO BE KEPT SECRET, NAME AND
ADDRESS WITHHELD ON THE IRS
FORM, CNN HAS CONFIRMED THE
SOURCE AS 90-YEAR-OLD
BUSINESSMAN AND PHILANTHROPIST
BARRY SIDE, WHO DONATED THE
ENTIRE STOCK OF HIS COMPANY TO
MARVEL FREEDOM TRUST, WHICH
TURNED AROUND AND SOLD IT FOR
$1.6 BILLION.
CNN HAS ATTEMPTED TO REACH
MR. SIDE WITHOUT RESPONSE.
HIS DONATION WILL LEAVE BEHIND A
DARK MONEY POLITICAL LEGACY THAT
COULD LAST DECADES.
ALREADY, MARBLE FREEDOM TRUST
HAS GIVEN MORE THAN $200 MILLION
TO OTHER CAUSES.
INCLUDING $40 MILLION TO DONORS
TRUST, WHICH HAS DOLED OUT
MILLIONS TO CONSERVATIVE CAUSES.
IN A STATEMENT TO CNN, LEONARD
LEO SAID IT'S HIGH TIME FOR THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT TO BE
AMONG THE RANKS OF GEORGE SOROS
AND OTHER LEFT-WING
PHILANTHROPISTS GOING TOE TO TOE
IN THE FIGHT TO DEFEND OUR
CONSTITUTION AND ITS IDEALS.
JAKE, THAT IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY DWARFS ANY
PREVIOUS DARK MONEY SINGLE
CONTRIBUTION WE COULD FIND, AND
CERTAINLY DWARVES THE LIBERAL
FUNDS LEONARD LEO IS
REFERENCING.
ONE OTHER NOTE OF SIGNIFICANCE,
ACCORDING TO TAX EXPERTS WE
TALKED TO, THIS DEAL LOOKS LIKE
IT'S SET UP SO AN ENTIRE COMPANY
IS DONATED AND THEN SO